you know offline you know I got a chance
to look at a bunch of thumbnails and
it's fascinating which ones do well
which ones don't is there something you
could say about what are the elements of
a thumbnail that work well is this also
deeply well that's where yeah it's the
same thing like how do you cook good
food but um it's easier if you pull up a
thumbnail that could be like that's why
that's good that's why that's bad that's
uh like an example would be like one of
my friends I was he just uploaded a
video recently and I called him I was
like what is this because he's a very
very smart guy and in the thumbnail he's
he's getting chased by cops but the cops
were wearing yellow vests so they didn't
look a cop so I was like whoa why are
the cops in your thumb wearing yellow
vests it's like that makes it so much
more boring and he was like carrying a
flag but the pole and the color of the
flag were the same color so it's like
it's a lot harder to see the flag I was
like also you're wearing like a shirt
with like five different colors like so
it's like it's hard to tell what even
what your outline is and then in the
background there were cars and I was
like well if you have cops chasing you
why not make the cars cop cars and you
know and it's like because in my head
I'm like dang if he just did those like
four or five things the video probably
got like seven extra views how much
iteration because I also got a chance to
see the number of iterations you do on a
I don't know it's a problem now it's an
addiction is it so you kind of
there's a lot of the versions were
really good yeah how do you know what
they're like I love how you when we
pulled up that uh the burger one and we
were flipping through him you're like
that's really good I was like oh that's
version like one of like a thousand but
even the sketch the idea was good like
already even the original idea is strong
yeah so we one of our coming up videos
we made the world's largest plant-based
burger and the thumbnail we were
thinking is like me standing beside the
bird because it's six feet tall that's
that's what he's talking about so like
just picture a giant six foot tall
burger super wide thousands of pounds
and then I'm beside it and then it's
like eating the world's largest burger
like you that's just something you have
to click like so you were saying like
how would you describe a good thumbnail
like that you know what I mean like but
I think you said the one I noticed first
that was good where you were very small
in it relative to the and you didn't
like that one I needed to come forward a
little bit and also the photo we took
was uh just my upper body so they photo
manipulated and created my legs
Photoshop and that's why I said I didn't
like it because my right leg was a
little like off it was like bit the
wrong way
does the physics and thumbnail have to
even make sense I mean you can just like
exaggerate the head size and all that
kind of yeah 100 yeah things don't have
to be relative yeah you can have a car
in the background be three times the
size yeah because yeah every one of my
thumbnails my face is in the you know
left side very big so brand recognition
so just people know oh especially
because now that a lot of people copy
our videos it's just nice to like you
know everyone else might make thumbnails
like this but this is mine and obviously
we usually over deliver and do bigger
stuff